[Music]
hey everyone my name is arjun and today
i'm going to be showing you guys
12 awesome tactics from real games so
with that out of the way let's get
started
so this first game was played between
stefan lewitsky and frank james marshall
frank marshall was one of the world's
first grand masters in the early 1900s
and he was playing black here
this game started off with d4 e6 e4
d5 so a transition into the french
defense
it continued like this
so here black will likely get an
isolated queen pawn but in exchange he
might get a lot of activity
castles bishop e7 bishop g5 castles
it's about equal here here white play d
takes c5 and instead of recapturing
black chose to play bishop e6 he's going
to recapture next
white played knight d4 black took on c5
white took on e6
and black to it back and here there are
several
um imbalances in the position so you'll
notice that white has the two bishops
which is generally an advantage in open
positions like these
black however has this open f file which
could end up being useful later
and you have these two hanging pawns
that's what it's called when you have
two pawns
which are not protected on either side
by any others so hanging pawns can
either be a weakness or a strength and
that just depends on how black plays
with them later in the game
here white played the move bishop g4
which is not a very good move
and that's because obviously it attacks
e6 but once white
once black protects e6 like he did in
the game with the move queen d6
the bishop is sort of misplaced there so
in the game why play bishop h3
because he doesn't want his what he
doesn't want black's knight to take it
and white and black brought his rook a
to e8
protecting this pawn and now his rooks
are on two pretty good files
next white play queen d2 getting his
queen out and black played bishop b4
white chose to take on f6 rook takes and
he played his rook to do one now
now black played queen c5 getting out of
this line with the queen with the queen
and the rook
and white played queen e2 and at first
this may look like it just loses a pawn
but white has a trick here so after it
takes
takes takes see if we can find it if i
can play
rook takes d5 and the idea is that if
black takes
then he'll take this rook and in this
specific situation
black will actually get mated in two
right after this sequence of moves
so of course marshall didn't fall for
that mating trick
after rook takes d5 he didn't take back
he played knight to d4
attacking the queen now if white plays a
move like queen e4
the game is about equal but he played a
very natural looking move that
completely loses
and that's queen to h5 this move
obviously attacks the black rook so he
should still not take care
but what black does here is he plays
rook e to f8 and this just doubles the
rooks on the file
and now he has a pretty important threat
which is rook takes f2
and the idea is that if rook takes f2
after rook takes back
then queen to e1 and if you calculate
that you'll see
that white's king is here and his rook
is here but black has this one rook on
the f file
so after white moves his rook back to f1
he black can take with the queen with
checkmate
so obviously white cannot allow that to
happen he plays rookie five
now black spots another tactic and
that's the move
rook to h6 and the idea behind this
tactic
is after most of white's moves white
played queen g5
black has another tactic in this
position can you find it
the move is rook takes h3 and the idea
behind this move is that if you take
back
knight f3 is a family fork it forks the
queen rook and king
so black would be completely winning
after this
white did not take back however and
instead he tried to move rick to c5
and here black has a stunning move which
wins the game and there are many winning
moves but black played the coolest and
also the best one
so i'll give you a moment to try and
look
the move is queen to g3
and the reason this wins is because is
because white
doesn't have any satisfactory response
and this move just looks really cool
aesthetically because
he's because black is putting the queen
where it can be taken by three different
pieces but they all lose
so um white has three responses really
if he moves the queen somewhere then
he's likely going to get mated
after some of these moves like this so
if white if white plays h takes g3 then
knight e2
is checkmate so he can't allow that to
happen
if he plays f takes g3 then black will
play 92
only legal move for white is king h1 and
rook takes f1 wins the game with mate
so white actually resigned here but if
you played the move queen takes g3
which is the only move that survives
pretty much white will play knight
black will play knight e2 and again
and white only has one legal move after
which black will play knight takes g3
and white is going to lose a lot of
material here because
he obviously cannot take with the h pawn
because it's pinned
if he takes with the f pawn then rook
takes f1 as mate
and the only other option is to play
king to g1 sorry
king to g1 and obviously he loses this
rook now
and after he takes back on h3 knight to
d2
and black is up a piece and is
completely winning
to the second tactic this one is very
similar to the first tactic
and it was played between nicolas
rossolimo who invented the rossolimo
variation of the sicilian
against paul reisman the game started
with
e4 e5 knight f3
knight c6 bishop c4
bishop c5 so the italian game
play continued like this
and in this position it may look as
though white has a big center so he
should be better
but black plays a good move here sorry
not knight to d5
he plays pawn d5 and this counters in
the center and it's about equal
here so what white does is he takes
takes and now white maybe has slightly
better development but he also has this
isolated d-pawn
so white plays queen to b3 and black
plays knight c to e7 protecting the
knight
and intending to play c6 in the future
with the pawn
white castles and black plays c6 as i
mentioned
and white plays rook fe1 just getting
the rook onto a good open file
and a lined up against the king
so black castles as well and white plays
a4
he wants to stop this idea of playing b5
so black plays b6 instead he wants to
fianchetto the bishop
white plays 95 getting onto an active
square
and a possible idea is that he can take
on c6
black takes back and take here this is a
possible idea for the future
but white black just plays bishop b7
and now white plays a white plays a5
and one possible idea after this move is
he wants to play a6
and then he'll force the bishop to
retreat probably to c8
so black plays b takes a5 here and this
is not a very
or sorry no he does not play b takes a
five that is a very bad move
then he loses the bishop like this so of
course he shouldn't let that happen
instead he plays rook to c8 which allows
this move to knight e4
and white's just trying to be more
aggressive here and attack on the king's
side in the future
so the black plays queen c7
uh white plays a6 bishop a8 queen h3
so he's just moving all of his pieces
over to king's side trying to attack on
that wing
black plays knight f4 attacking the
queen and after queen g4
knight e to g5 so now these two knights
are sort of connected like this
which can be good or it can be bad so
white plays rook a3 here which may look
like a strange move at first
but the idea is that the rook wants to
go along the third rank
so that's called a rook lift and it's an
important motif
black plays 96 bringing his knight back
and white plays this tactical sequence
bishop takes d5 c takes d5 knight f6
and after kh8 the only legal move white
plays a really nice move here
which is very reminiscent of the first
position
can you find it
the move is queen to g6 and
there are many this is reminiscent of
the first position because in the
previous one
black played queen to g3 this is
essentially the same except it's
mirrored
so black has two recaptures he has h
take g6
which of course will fail to rook h3
mate
and he has f takes g6 but this also gets
mated because after knight takes g6
h take g6 only move rook h3 is still
made
so of course he loses after these
options and in the game
uh what black did is he played queen to
c2
and the concept is of course if white
takes that would not be a good move
because he would just take back
but uh white found another pretty cool
move here
see if you can find it that move
is rook to h3 and
he actually has mate and 7 here but
instead of allowing that black just
resigned
and just some possible variations are if
you take with the f pawn
then white will take on h7 mate and if
you take
the queen it's not much better because
after knight takes
only it'll move checkmate and
of course if you play any alternative
white's definitely going to mate you
because he's got all of these pieces
aimed on the king's side
on to the third puzzle
this third game was played between bobby
fischer and sam
samuel rashevsky and both of these
players were very good at one point in
time
but fischer actually managed to obtain a
winning position in less than 15 moves
which is very rare at the grand master
level the game started out with a
sicilian defense
e4 c5 and fischer continue with knight
f3
knight t6 d4 open sicilian
all pretty standard so far
and here black played the first mistake
of the game he played the move knight a5
which is a very natural move
perhaps he saw fisher's reply but he
didn't see what fischer would do after
that
so the idea is obviously he wants to
take on b3
so instead of protecting this bishop
fischer played the move e5
and he's attacking this knight and if
black takes on b3 that would not be very
good for him because after e takes f6
obviously if you take back then white
takes and he'll be up a piece
so you have to take on a1 pretty much
and after
takes king takes this knight is going to
lose
is going to fall and once white takes it
at some at now
or later then he'll have he'll have two
pieces for a rook which is generally a
favorable advantage
but instead of losing some material
rashford played the move 98
and white only has one winning move here
can you find it
if white plays any other natural move
then he isn't going to be winning
but i'm going to show the move that move
is bishop takes f7
and now black only has three little
moves
but of course what if he takes back the
idea here
is well this is another tactic so see if
you can find it
the idea is he's going to play knight e6
and this traps the queen
if you take then obviously queen takes
d8 and whites up a queen
and the knight and bishop worked
perfectly together because they covered
the queen's only
escape squares so the queen cannot
escape therefore this move wins the
queen
instead if black tries taking the king
as he did in the actual game
knight e6 is played again and obviously
you cannot take
because of queen takes d8 these two
squares are still covered by the knight
in bishop
and if you take with the king there's a
pretty nice mating sequence here
and it goes like this queen
to d5 check king f5
g4 this sacrifices a pawn with track but
also opens up lines for the rook
so the rook can join the battle now
if he plays king h4 this is the best
resistance basically
and what white should do is he should
just play something like queen e4
now you can play king h3 but after that
after queen g2
king h4 queen g4 it'll be made and there
are similar mates and many other
variations
so if we go back to what actually
happened in the game
from this position what rashevsky did is
he just took with the pawn
and he decided to be down a queen but i
won't go through the rest of the game
and fischer won pretty easily
this fourth this fourth game was taken
from a rapid game between victor corsnoy
former world championship challenger
and ilya smirin
so this started out corsonoy playing
white
with d4 knight f6 c4 g6 so a king's
indian
knight c3 bishop g7 e4 d6
bishop g5 h6 bishop e3 knight g4 bishop
c1
so black is just attacking white's
bishop over and over again
and he or she plays e5 d5 and f5
so this is a typical king's indian
breakthrough since
black is trying to attack on the king
side in this line
takes takes h3 knight f6 knight
goes to e2 and f4 so black wants to gain
space on the king side
white plays queen d3 getting his queen
out and castles
and already here it looks as though
black's position is probably a bit
favorable
because he has more space and he's
already castled with slightly better
development
white plays g3 he's trying to make a
dent in his pawn in black's pawn
structure
and black plays e4 knight takes
knight takes knight takes queen takes so
neither side is playing perfectly here
there have been some inaccuracies but
this was a rapid game
so yeah black plays bishop f5 here
and the position is about equal after
this move white is down
oh sorry no not white black is down upon
but black has
good development and he has more space
at least on the king side he has more
active pieces that is
white plays queen f3 he does not want
this extra pawn
black plays knight a6 getting his knight
developed it might go to b4 or perhaps
c5 after this
white plays bishop g2 getting his bishop
out preparing for castling
knight c5 is played threatening to go
knight d3 and here white chooses to play
gta f4 which looks a bit surprising at
first
especially considering after knight d3
king f1 white has lost his right to
castle
and in this position i would definitely
take white i would definitely take black
hero sorry
because he just has more space more
active pieces
and a safer king but the position is
actually only slightly better for black
he plays rookie 8 now getting his rook
onto this good file
white plays queen h5 attacking the
bishop and he plays queen f6 protecting
it
now white plays bishop bishop f3 and the
idea is he wants to go king g2
and bring his rook out so it's sort of
like he was castling by hand
now knight takes b2 is played and after
takes
takes black has won back one of his
pawns
and white plays the move king g2 here
protecting his rook like this
now black plays bishop d3 attacking this
knight
so the move rook a to e1 is played
and the knight's protected three times
and although it although black's
position
is about equal here i would probably
take black just because
he's only down one pawn and white has
these lots of weaknesses all around the
board
however black's next move is a blunder
he played the move queen before
attacking this rook can you see why i'll
give you a moment to find out
all right the move for white is to play
knight c1
and here black actually just resigned so
the reason this
is winning is because he's obviously
attacking white's bishop
black's bishop sorry and a discovered
attack on this rook
so if black moves his bishop somewhere
rook takes wins a rook
then obviously the only other
alternative really is just to take on e1
and here white can play knight takes d3
and
this is a fork so normally what black
would do is he would take on h1 but here
of course he'll lose his queen after
that
and if you move the queen somewhere then
after a move like knight or rook takes
e1
white is completely winning so i think
that this tactic is especially hard to
find
just because it's a backwards knight
move and we don't tend to look for those
as much
the fifth game was played between edward
lasker and george allen thomas
edward lasker being related to emmanuel
alaska former world champion
the game started with
d4 e6 knight f3 f5 so the dutch defense
knight c3 knight f6 bishop g5 bishop b7
takes takes e4 takes takes
so black does have the bishop pair but
white has a better development
and more center black plays b6
white plays knight e5 and now he's just
got his knight to a pretty good square
and it's still about equal here
black castles white plays bishop d3
and black plays bishop b7 and now white
plays queen h5
with a pretty important threat here if
black plays a random move like a6 for
example
then after knight after knight takes f6
it's not actually the best move in this
specific position
but this is just the general idea and if
you take back
then white will take and it's pretty
clear that he's going to be matings
not after that move after this move
so uh obviously black would not just do
nothing
he tried to protect in his own way the
best moves to play bishop e5
and if white takes back it's about equal
still here
but he tried to play a creative move
queen to e7
and this move actually just loses and
it's actually made in seven for white
here
now the idea that that black had
intended here was after knight takes f6
g takes f6 he's discovered protecting
this pawn
and it's equal here but instead white
played a really nice move
which completely refutes brock's idea
i'll give you a moment to find it
move that white played here is queen
takes h7
and now it's actually mate in six for
white
so i'll just show you the line that
happened it was king takes g7
knight takes f6 king h6 once again
only move if you play instead of
king h6 king h8 then knight g6 is made
in one
king h6 knight e to g4 once again only
move he played the move h4
there are two alternatives the other one
is f4 which
will also lead to a quick mate but
he played the move h4 king f4 is played
g3 once again only move for black
and here uh white played the move bishop
to e2
check and this leads to maintenance iii
but uh white can play a slightly cooler
move here which will lead to a faster
mate
let's see if you can find it
so there are actually two moves here
which are made in two one of them is to
play castles
which is a very unusual move in this
type of position
since normally when you're attacking you
don't want to castle but this actually
leads to
a pretty nice mate after this and
no matter what black plays actually
let's say he makes a queen move
knight h2 is made after all the
responses
the other way to mate in two moves is to
play king f1
which is the exact same purpose knight
h2 will be made no matter what
but last year continued playing with all
checks
bishop e2 king g2 then he played rook
h2 forcing the king to the back rank
and here he entered the game by playing
king d2 which is mate in one
and it's very rare that you get to
checkmate with a king move but another
move you could play was just to castle
queenside
which is also made
the sixth game from from these twelve is
between grand master esteban canal
versus an unnamed player in a simul
so canal had white uh he played e4 and
his opponent played d5 so
the scandinavian defense takes takes
knight c3 queen a5 he played d4
c6 knight f3 bishop g4
bishop f4 e6 so all pretty much normal
he played h3 takes takes bishop b4
white played bishop e2 and black played
97 both sides were just continuing their
development
and white played the move a3 and first
of all this is not actually a threat
because if black plays some random move
if you take
and then you lose this rook
so uh black just a black just uh ignored
the threat for now
he played the move castles which is a
very natural move but it actually leads
to a completely lost position
and white played the move i just
mentioned actually he played the move a
takes b4 but can you see why
i'll give you a moment
so of course black uh once black takes
then uh that's obviously the only good
move if he just moves his queen
somewhere else
then there was pretty much no point in
actually in actually allowing this
so in the game black did indeed take
white played king g2
which gives up another rook actually
so in the game black obviously took this
it doesn't really matter what he does
since you might have seen the threat by
now but if you did you'll notice that
all of these squares are actually
covered
so the only move the queen can go
without losing itself is to play queen
b2
which will lead to the same fate as in
the game or to take on a1
or sorry h1 he ended up taking on h1
and after the move queen to take c6
this leads to a cool checkmate with two
diagonally
with two uh crossing bishops essentially
after b takes c6 he played the move
bishop a6
which is checkmate so note how this
bishop covers these squares but this
other bishop covers these scores and
this
is a really nice pattern when it comes
up in games like it did here
the next game was played between
dimitrios mastrovolusis i'm not sure if
i pronounced that right
against nigel short so
master of alice's had white and he
played e4 c6
so the caracon defense and they played
the two knights variation
so these are all normal moves for both
sides so far
h4 he wants to gain space on the king
side perhaps
black played b5 trying to do the same
thing on the queen side
they both continued and he played 92 so
e2 is a pretty flexible scare for the
knight it can
it can go to both sides from this
position
uh castles this is not a good move from
black and the reason is just because
it's sort of castling right into white's
attack
and i don't know about you but white's
attack definitely looks more scary to me
just because this rook it i feel like it
can get into the attack more easily
like that so white played move queen g3
just trying to continue attacking
basically takes takes
kha and king trade is a kind of a slow
move like
black should probably be trying to
attack on the queen side if anything but
instead he's just trying to uh save
himself on the king side
so now white plays h6 g6 and bishop f4
and this move is aiming for this
diagonal potentially or if he's
intending to trade off for this bishop
just so white so black will have no
control over all these weak dark squares
so
black played queen e8 and white did what
i mentioned
he played there and f6 this is trying to
just block off this diagonal
so i played the move knight d4
threatening this pawn
and black protected of course and here
white just decided to continue attacking
by playing bishop c4
bishop takes rook takes
c5 attacking the rook he plays rook to
d2
and knight to b6 so now
uh white didn't white um if he takes
this pawn that's not good
because obviously that hangs the bishop
so uh
he plays queen to b3 protecting this
bishop and also sort of going on a
battery against this piece
so he takes the bishop trying to get rid
of one of white's best pieces
white recaptures and the move rook f to
see it is played
so this gets on the same line as the
queen and also
now bishop take c5 is sort of a bit
riskier
although i ended up playing this in the
game anyway because now
it's kind of hard to protect it as well
so black played the move knight g8 here
and what he wants to do is he wants to
bring his queen over and take this
bishop
but white played the move rook hd1 and
it may seem as though he's just ignoring
black's threat
but actually white had a really nice
response intended for her to move queen
c7
black end up playing remove queen c7 so
can you find white's next move
pause the video if you need more time
the move is to play bishop f8
and the reason this move works is it's
all playing on the idea of this weak
square on g7
so of course it looks like it hangs the
queen but if you take the queen
bishop g7 is maiden one which is a
really cool mate and it's actually how
the game
ended now of course if you take the
bishop
then taking on c7 would win the queen
and it'll also probably be made in a few
moves because
just of how active white's pieces are
so uh the only other way that you can
try to survive really
i suppose is to play knight h6 but at
the very least what you can do is you
can just play
queen c7 rook c7 bishop h6 and white's
just winning here
this eighth game was played between two
former world champions gary kasparov and
wish
and vishwanathan anand so kasparov had
white
and although this tactic that occurred
in the game was pretty simple if a world
champion fell for it i think it should
be probably pretty useful to know
so start off with knight f3 d5 c4 c6
so after d4 turns into the slav defense
knight f6 knight c3 takes a4
so all pretty much mainline stuff
bishop f5 e3 e6 takes bishop b4
so all just normal moves castles castles
queen e2 knight b to d7 95
getting knight onto a pretty active
square rookie 8
rook d1 queen c7 now he's double
attacking this knight
so white takes on d7 takes
f3 he might attend e4 now trying to
build up his center
and move knight d5 and this move does
not lose
because if you play the move e4 which is
not what happened in the game
then you can take on c3 with the bishop
and once you take back if you take back
that is
takes you have to move the queen takes
here and in this position even though
white's going to get this pawn back
this bishop has this bishop and this
rook haven't moved
and once he gets his rook here these two
rooks will be pretty active
so the position is still equal even
though white has two bishops for a rook
but that did not happen in the game
uh instead of playing instead of playing
e4 he played the move knight e2
knight a2 sorry and he wants to take
this bishop
probably soon so black played bishop f8
just getting it out of harm's way
e4 is played now and the reason this
move still doesn't technically win
anything
is because after bishop g6
takes you can take back this way and
once the queen moves you'll get your
piece back
so kasparov still didn't take and
instead he played the move queen e1
which it has these two nice diagonals to
go on
and e1 is generally a useful square for
the queen that is if the nothing else is
occupying it
just because it can go on both sides of
the board pretty easily
so this move also actually sets a really
nice trap which on and fell for
he played the move f5 just trying to
attack in the center
and if white didn't have his next move
this would be a pretty good move
but white has kind of a tactic here
actually
the the hard part is seeing why it's a
tactic actually
he plays the move he takes d5 like i
said earlier and you might think
well once black takes back isn't he just
going to win the bishop anyway
but no that's actually not the case once
pl once
this move play is played white plays the
move bishop e2
and note that when the queen was on e2
in this position
the e2 square was occupied so the bishop
couldn't be saved
but once you get to this position
after this move the e2 squared is not
occupied
so if the game had continued uh black
actually resigned after he takes d5
queen e7 rook d2 and now white can just
maneuver around his pieces say queen to
d1
bishop f1 and he'll be up a piece and
winning
so this ninth game was played between
maxine bashir lagrave a world-class gm
right now
against claude landenburg who was in the
2400s
so vashir lagrav had white and he played
e4
e5 knight of three knight c6 bishop b5
knight g to e7
so this is not a very common move but
it's not necessarily bad
so castle's there d4 takes takes
bishop d7 knight c3 and black's position
is slightly passive in this position
so he took on d4 he's trying to trade
off pieces which is generally a good
thing in these types of positions
if uh as a rule of thumb if you're
cramped it's better to trade off pieces
and black is definitely a bit cramped so
takes takes takes queen d4
knight c6 is played he's attacking the
queen queen d3 bishop e7
queen to g3 he's attacking this pawn and
black sensing danger on the kingside
instead chose to castle queenside
and white played bishop e3 here
continuing his development
and in general you should avoid taking
uh the pawns in front of your king even
if they're the opposing players pawns
and that's just because it can lead to
an attack potentially on the king's side
so white played the move bishop e3
just continuing his development g6 is
played
protecting the pawn just in case for the
future knight d5s played
and f5 so now uh white is better here
now
because f5 is a bit of a weakening move
and he plays b4
and after black plays the move rook d to
e8 it doesn't do too much
he plays the move b5 and now he's
attacking this knight which is an
important defender of the queen side
so after 95 white took on a7
and this is not the best move but white
is still better here for sure
so black hook on b5 white played bishop
d4
now pinning this knight to the rook and
queen c4 is played just attacking the
bishop
so now rook after d1 so white is still
much better here but black's next move
f takes e4 allows for a really nice
tactic
and it's it's a combination and it's not
very easy to see especially from afar
so pause the video if you'd like to find
out i'm going to show the tactic
the move is bishop takes e5 which
doesn't seem like
all that special of a move really at
first but once you get further to attack
you'll see why
so the reason this move is a bit
surprising is just because generally
it's not good to trade a bishop for a
night
but since white has a tactic obviously
it's a pretty important exception
so it takes back and knight takes e7 and
here black resigned
seeing the tactic but i'll continue
playing through it just in case
you want to see it that is after the
move rook takes e7
queen i3 is a fork and it threatens this
rook
but also threatens checkmate in the
corner and that's what claude landenburg
didn't see at first
so of course if you move the rook that's
checkmate
and if you stop mate then you lose the
rook
so that's tactic number nine
this tenth tactic came from a game
between siegbert tarish who was a grand
master in the early 1900s
against a group of players who were
allowed to talk about the position with
one another
so trash started with the move f4 d5 so
bird's opening
and he continued with knight f3 c5
e3 knight c6 so this looks sort of like
a reverse dutch at this point
bishop b5 bishop d7 castles e6
b3 queen c7 bishop b2
f6 so he's trying to blunt this bishop's
diagonal and also play for e5
he plays the move c4 now just countering
the center really
and after knight c to e7 this is not a
very good move just because it's moving
the same piece twice
and also taking up a square where the
previous knight might have gone
so after this move white played knight
to c3
and intending that after takes of course
he'll take back probably with the knight
so uh blacklight knight h6 and this just
proves that knight cd7 was not good
because the knight would have gone to e7
most likely originally but obviously it
can't now
so white plays the move rook to c1
getting on the same line as the queen
and after bishop takes knight takes
black
black realized that and played queen to
d7
now after moved queen to e2 getting the
queen out
black plays knight back to c6 even after
moving it back to e7 in the first place
takes takes e4 just opening up the
center
since black is not castled yet and black
castle queenside
and at first this looks like and i even
thought that this was probably a pretty
bad move
but now thinking about the position i
realized that black doesn't really have
much choice
and the reason is just because the
center is opening up so obviously black
wants to get out of the center
but the only way he can do that in a
timely manner is to play castle's queen
side so that's what he did
now white played e5 now and
the move that was played here was a6
attacking the knight
and after knight c3 b5 is played
and this move just looks a bit risky
aesthetically because he's opening up
the center and moving
well not the center but he's opening up
the side where his king is castled
by moving the pawns there
so white played a4 here
trying to take advantage of black's
inaccuracies and after the move b4
of course it may seem as though this
pawn is hanging and that is true
but terrash didn't want to go through
this because the queens would get traded
and he felt like his chances lied more
if the queens didn't get traded
so after the move b4 he played knight d1
he just wanted to continue the attack
and this move is still good white is
still definitely better
so he played king to b7 protecting the
pawn
e takes f6 g takes f6 rook f6 bishop f6
sorry and
uh black played rookie eight which
attacks the queen and therefore he's not
going to lose a rook
okay well no sorry that was not the
correct line
so white played knight e3 and the move
d4 is bad because the rook is still
hanging
so instead before doing that black
played the move rook to g8
and the move continued and the game
continued like this
queen d3 knight g4 knight takes
queen takes rook f2 protecting mate
queen d7
95 knight takes bishop takes rook c8
and although not much has happened over
the last 10 moves or so
white still has a pretty solid advantage
so he plays the move queen f3 now which
threatens this pawn even though it's
protected and sets up a pin
black plays king b6 he wants to get out
of the pin and after move d3
uh perhaps he wants to get his rook over
like this this is probably the most
efficient way of doing so
the move bishop h6 is played getting the
bishop developed
rook after c2 d4
and white plays a really nice move here
this is not the final tactic
but it still is a good move and the move
is a5
and this is sort of trying to flush the
king out
so of course if black takes this is
actually the best move rook takes
rook takes rook takes and after like
king to b6
white will play rook to d5 and all of
his pieces are aiming at the king and
he's completely winning in this position
so black probably saw this so instead he
played the move king to b5 which hold on
to this pawn for now
and now white played one of the best
moves out of all of these tactics
actually
so i'll give you a moment to see if you
can find it pause the video if you need
more time
i'm going to show the move now the move
is bishop to c7
and it's actually mate in four
surprisingly
so the reason that this move wins is
because first of all it's threatening to
move queen to b7
so if black does nothing then queen to
b7 is made in one
and coin coincidentally
rook takes c5 is also made in one so he
has two threats
so if if black plays the move or kicks
c7
then you can play queen b7 which is a
really cool way of mating because after
rook takes
then rook c5 is checkmate
so if you don't play rook to c7 and
instead you play queen take c7
then you can do the same mate basically
except in just in the opposite order
play rook takes e5 first queen takes and
then queen b7
so if you block with the queen here's
mate
and if you take over here then this is
made
so anyway that's all for this tactic on
to number 11.
so i decided to feature two carlson
tactics to end the dozen
and this first one was actually played
in a blindfold game which makes it even
more impressive
against sergey karyakin
so it started off in the sicilian
nothing too interesting so far
f4 takes castles knight g6
queen h5 d6 and both sides are making
some mistakes
but it was a blindfolded game so i think
they can be excused for that
so bishop takes f4 knight takes f4 rook
f4 and g6
so now obviously it's not a threat to
take there anymore
so white played the move queen f3 bishop
g7
uh and it may look as though he's going
to lose a piece here because after rook
f7
if the queen moves then this will happen
but black has the move bishop d4
and although it may not look like it the
move the position is actually about
equal here
so he played king king to h1 queen d8
and it may seem as though white must be
winning here obviously because
he's got this monster attack and he's
got a really active knight
but uh black is actually equal here
about because he's got all of these
threats
and even though his king isn't safe the
rest of his threats make up for that
so uh white played c3 so if you take
then takes back but black play bishop e5
saving his piece for now
and rook g7 is played and the idea is
that this move is threatening checkmate
in one
so if you take or do pretty much
anything that doesn't protect against
this threat
queen f7 wins
so after we move rook g7 queen f6 was
played
and this is offering a queen trade and
although karjakin probably had
calculated a head at this point
after queen takes f6 bishop f6 rook h7
you might think that uh black has that
white has gotten a pawn
and so he shouldn't be too much worse
and in fact if black didn't have his
next tactic the position would be just
equal
but see if you can find this move it's
really cool i'll give you a few seconds
the move is castles and how often is
castle is the only winning move really
and that's part of the reason i like
this tactic so much but i'll just show
some of the lines that could occur
of course if you move the knight then
this rook will hang
and vice versa if you move the rook the
knight will hang
and that's just what makes this tactic
really cool because these two are just
sort of dependent on one another
and so you can't really do anything so
what happened in the game was knight a3
just giving away this knight and once
the rook moves it went to c7
then the rest of the game just continued
like this i won't bother
talking about it since it's not too
difficult
and pretty good technique from carlson
at the end of course you can't take the
bishop because of checkmate
so that was this tactic and the final
tactic out of these 12
was actually played by carlson when he
was only 12 years old and he was a 2100
player at the time
but this tactic is actually very
difficult to find in a real game i know
i keep saying that but it's true
and i just thought it was a useful
tactic to show regardless of his rating
at the time
so carlson had white it went in the
french defense like this
so this is the torah variation of the
french named after one of the players
from an earlier game
so carlson is going to sacrifice a pawn
in exchange for a better development
and that's how the game proceeded
knight f3 so carlson is down a pawn but
he's got
uh pretty good pieces here and his
king's already safe so the position is
even
so queen b6 he plays queen a4 getting
his queen out
queen b4 this move offers to trade and
in general just as another rule of thumb
you should only trade if you're ahead of
material or if you have
pretty much a space disadvantage so
obviously carson's behind in material
and it looks like he probably does have
more space since he's got this active
pawn right here
so he plays the move queen to c2 just
getting out of line of the threat
black continues insisting on the trade
but white escapes yet again
then black continues developing fish b3
queen a5
bishop g5 this time carlson's offering
to trade
and i said it was an exception and the
exception is still true
but uh in this case uh it's not a good
idea to trade and that's just because
in general it's just a bad idea to trade
as i mentioned earlier
so what his opponent should do is he
should just take and after takes he
should play something like h6
and once the knight comes back then he's
traded off a set of pieces
in this position i'd say this bishop is
definitely better than this one
so this is not a good move but instead
his opponent played
queen to d8 so uh what white did in the
game he should play something like
bishop e7 now
but he played the move queen e3 and
after takes
he of course would not take back with
the queen since he does not want to
trade queens
he instead took on the knight so now
uh black made the move queen e7 and
white played rook a to c1 a natural move
and here he creates a threat that black
completely missed
black trade was probably the most
natural move but it's also an incred
it's also a really bad move in this
position
that move that he played is h6 and in a
blitz game
probably most people would play this as
well and just the reason for this is
because it's a very natural move and
generally you're not going to look for
tactics in the opening
but what carlson did is he played a
really nice move it's also very hard to
find actually
even though the tactic is quite simple
you guys should try to look for it for a
moment
all right the move is queen takes a7
so as i said before this move is very
hard to find
and that's just because it doesn't look
like it's going to be it doesn't look
like there's going to be any tactic in
this type of position
but there just happens to be one so if
if black takes then after the move rook
c8
queen d8 only they go move takes takes
knight f7 white's going to win the rook
next move and be up and be up in a piece
so in the game carlsen's opponent
realized that he played rook b8
but he's still losing after queen takes
knight takes and rook c rook c8
so after king to d7 rook takes h8
now uh you can't really take here i mean
technically you can
but after rook takes v8 carlson would
have
uh two rooks and a bishop for a queen
which is an overwhelming material
advantage
so i'll just show how the game went on
his opponent played knight to c6 knight
f3 f6
and white went on to win the game like
this
and here he was forced to do this pretty
much because otherwise he's going to get
mated here
so after takes takes here black resigned
and carlson won the game
so anyway those are my 12 tactics from
real games i hope you guys enjoyed and
i'll see you next time
you